I think the libraries can help communicate knowledge about what is happening.
They can be the bank for the climate change.
They can create communication as well as images and translate the scientific language for the citizens to understand.
However, I don’t think they can do this by themselves.
They need to form an alliance with artists in a broad sense; actors, sculptors, painters.
People who are used to tell stories using a whole other language than they speak in the libraries.
I believe we need to use an artistic, symbolic language to make people comprehend
the tremendous changes that are currently happening to the Earth,
as well as to piece together hope and how to reconstruct a new society, which will not replicate climate change.
How to get out on the other side of this situation.